they they're smaller size is too big for
me and I'm yeah I know I guess that is
like me but it's a real struggle like
small people it does suck wait that you
can choose from kid sizes and adult
sizes the sizes are never that you never
had to buy like bind your feet your
whole life little people don't need
sneakers like where are you going oh my
God
are you
right now go to nativedeo.com trash
Tuesday or use promo code trash Tuesday
or at checkout to get a sweet 20 off
your first order that's native
deo.com trash Tuesday or use promo code
trash Tuesday at checkout for 20 off
your first order you can grow thicker
healthier hair and support our show by
going to neutriful.com and entering the
promo code trash to save 15 off your
first month subscription this is their
best offer anywhere and it is only
available to us customers for a limited
time plus free shipping on every order
get 15 off at nutrifold.com spelled
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l.com promo code trash New
York City slugs tickets for my New York
shows are finally on sale today at 1pm
Eastern I cannot wait I'm gonna be at
Joe's Pub you can get tickets at Esther
onice.com these shows are going to be
really really special
um and intimate and I can't wait by the
way I love New York I want to live here
I love it so much
[Music]
at okay that's giving kickline camp
what is kickline Camp
dude you're you think you're joking but
like you're really good Hannah that was
pretty good and modern Dan and I'm tired
for the rest of the Pod now nobody cares
about modern dance but it is a really
like you could be in a modern dance I
just feel like you're you just have to
pick a story in your head and I make up
different stories in my head all the
time and then I just like acted out
excessively and you express literally
out of breath you guys I walked up La
Cienega today people thought I was in
out of shape prostitute like okay that's
a humble brag
no but like if you're a girl walking in
L.A people just think you're a
prostitute who like isn't pretty enough
for only fans and I like was gonna faint
and no one wanted to pick me up also how
I know you're not from La is because we
all ordered LA colombe and you asked for
whole milk
he said what kind of milk I said normal
milk and he did not process it he was
like normal oats
normal macadamia nuts
um so I am gonna [__] myself but that's
part of my thing I also just got a
lymphatic drainage massage oh I love
those she's glowing and in the beginning
she started telling me like
manifestations like she was like you are
beautiful you are worthy you and I was
like I'm not in New York anymore New
York I'd be like shut the [__] up I'm
just trying to get a massage I know
quiet down you crusty [__] I'm like you
don't know me [__] I'm actually not
worthy I don't know if I'm going to be
because I'm gonna go to New York for the
month of March I don't know if I'm gonna
be able to handle it I'm very accustomed
to people giving you affirmations when
you wake up yeah
but you have a bite to you
yeah I think of you as a poisonous dart
frog oh my God that's the sweetest thing
anyone's ever said I'm and I'm getting
nastier they're deadly yes they're
deadly are you in your villain era I
think I'm in my like just Embrace how
[__] dark I really am yeah like I'm
not holding back anymore I've always
loved your sense of humor and now I
realize it's because Underneath It All
is the saddest
but it comes off so bubbly so it's so
confusing and I'm obsessed with that for
you okay so back to us all being former
after oh yeah sorry so no no for my
presentation because I do have a
question I am my whole life I was like
oh my God you know you meet people who
when you were when I was dancing when
you were doing your you know respective
athletic programs chasing balls
people would always come up to me and be
like oh I used to dance and I'd be like
is that gonna be me one day that can't
be me that can't be me everything is
going and then now that is me and um I
have to struggle with like
not being ashamed to go to a ballet
class here and there and feel like it
has been but now when I get over that
and I go I feel wonderful and I'm like
oh it's okay that this is a beautiful
hobby for me do you guys relate to that
at all a hundred percent but I leaned
into my has been title a long time ago I
just go I'm a husband but it's kind of
like it's it's like a defensive thing to
say I think because what happens is that
when I was when I quit swimming and like
three years after that I would go back
to the Rose Bowl and I'll do a couple
laps and there was still that part of me
that was still really competitive where
like the person lap swimming next to me
I was like this [__] young person
doesn't know who the [__] I am and then
but then I'm like wait a second like I
as opposed to I could just admit that
I'm a has been but when he would like we
would be on the wall together
you know I would make sure that there
was conversation and that he knew like
you know what I mean like what you have
I was once there yeah because think
about it that skill made people respect
us in the past and then you have that
identity crisis where you're like who am
I without this thing that made me
important and people loved me more when
I would win more when I do these cool
dance moves and I what I had to realize
for myself because after I quit I would
like cry all the time because I'd be
like why did you put 20 years into
something and none of your dreams even
like yeah I just got the chills no I
literally would be like what was the
reason like hard to be like what was why
did I literally push myself so [__]
hard and then I realized like what made
you special in that sport in that Talent
is you're gonna put into so many other
things and like now that makes more
sense to me but like when I was 23
I was kind of empty and I had to figure
it out but also a lot of people we are
dualities like we have we're so
multifaceted but Society tries to put
you into like you're a swimmer yeah and
I think especially with women like we
have so many parts of ourselves that but
people want to like name us as one thing
yeah that is a really interesting thing
that I think not a lot of non-athletes
don't understand is the identity crisis
because that is your entire being like
the entire self-awareness of who you are
is tied to this thing you do every day
and you do it blindly you don't ask
questions you just put in the work
because you think you're gonna make it
to the Olympics one day or make you know
what I mean or win Wimbledon you know
win a grand slam you know dance at UNLV
like you just think it's so you believe
it's so hard so when it's over you're
like what now who am I outside of this
am I you know like do I even know how to
[__] tie my shoelaces like do I know
how to live alone like who am I in
relation to this person it's a total
identity crisis and like I do find
myself when I go to professional ballet
classes and I can't pick up certain
moves I I like shut down I'm like you
know what I'm doing so bad at picking up
this combination I just stand at the
back of a room and watch because I'm
like I can't even like fight the fight
sometimes but then other times I'm like
these little [__] I got better feet
than them my turnout is better like
there's just so much that comes up in
there and and I what I don't want to
happen anymore is for me to be be so
bummed out about it that it keeps me
from finding the love in it well that's
the thing like by the end sometimes
we've lost love we were burnt out but
like I have the tennis channel on all
day every day really I just watch
breakpoint yes so good the thing is
tennis is it's a mental mess they say
the cord is six inches from ear to ear
or if you have a small head do you have
something to say oh no he looks really
interested oh no I just like that show
on Netflix
little feet but I realized that like
with tennis
I I'll jump in and I'll play with people
and in the past you have all these
voices in your head you don't have a
voice as an athlete or a dancer it's
what are your coaches saying what are
your parents saying you numb your voice
and then once you quit you're just left
with this like weak inner voice that my
only job was how high how so then you
have to literally find who that voice is
whoa that's a really good point that was
so I've done like a lot of therapy I can
tell and also I love hearing you say
that you watch Tennis all the time
because there are certain series that
have come out over the past few years
that are about dance and I'm like too I
can't watch that I'm the same way I
can't watch swimming but I'll watch
Tennis all day but I also don't miss a
grand slam like I oh I mean it's a lot
of chic iconic we should go we should go
to the Palm Spring oh my God I re I'm so
pissed that I've never been in a single
one it is so fun and to see it I mean
tennis is also I'm obsessed with tennis
and I'm also swimming and dance they're
all kind of
like there's team but there's not it's
an individual with tennis you can't call
time out when you're feeling bad you
can't pass the ball you can't get
coached it's literally you out there
figuring it out and same with swimming
you can't be like wait can we restart or
like dance you have to figure it out and
I think we we all were kind of these
like solo performers that found a
different way
um to express ourselves
yeah we should go to Palm Springs okay I
didn't realize the prize money was so
big for these big tournaments it is but
with tennis the problem is is if you're
not in the top 150 in the world you're
making no money it's like really hard to
break into them so my thing was like I
was fully like I could go pro but I will
lose all my money and make it like maybe
500 in the world with a 500th best like
a level this is a sports podcast now the
500th best like basketball players
making tons of money sitting on a bench
whether he wins or lose he gets paid
that's my kind of career I've been I've
been lucky though
um where I've been able to Parlay my
ability to swim into other things so now
I'm fully into free diving and spear
fishing and that that's where I've found
the love for a while that's something
I'd pretend to like if a guy was hot I'm
like I love spear fishing
I think about all the time
the amount of things I pretended to like
for guys I always say I still don't even
know how I truly feel about magic
because everyone
ever dated has had such a strong feeling
either hating it or loving it and I
always am switching it up like wait did
you say Free Falling free diving free
diving that's kind of thing I'd like do
you want a free dive and I'm like I'm so
spontaneous
hurt your toe right before you're like
oh my God this is so weird I should
check this I'll be in the van
so [__] cool
so you have it's a drug like performing
was a drug so I lost that drug and then
I guess like stand-up is performing has
given us this thing but we also have the
diligence of a disciplined athlete
combined with creativity and that's why
we're taking over the [__] planet
however I was triggered driving here
today I saw these people running in like
a CrossFit class and I realized like I
was so emotionally and physically abused
as an athlete like you're just because
your coaches they're only PR their
pressure is that you're number one right
yeah so they don't care they're like I'm
gonna push you my mom had to tell my
coaches that they had to tell me to stop
because I wouldn't like I would just
like I would have no foot left like I
would just keep going which is like what
made me good but also like that's
traumatic so I told myself when I
graduated I'm like I'm never running a
Time mile again I'm never waking up to
work out before 7 A.M thank you and I've
stuck to it Hannah we have the same
exact rules do we have the same
therapist maybe because she was like no
competition for you not in any facet you
are not allowed to
you're flipping the table with Monopoly
nothing absolutely no competition in
fact she says if you're gonna do a spin
class it's got to be only Soul cycle
because they don't measure your RPMs
there are no numbers it cannot be the
other cycle houses where your
competitive side was what made people
like think you were amazing before so
how do you decipher what is good for you
competitive wise versus what's unhealthy
um so it triggers a whole like slew of
just like uh physical shutdown for me
where it's like I can perform in a
competition and if I go to that Cycle
house if I go anywhere I probably will
win because I will die before I lose
yeah but so I go home and I'm
emotionally just like or I'm just I'm a
rep so I quit tennis because I had
horrible performance anxiety I see that
a lot with tennis players like I would
like lose my serve like I was playing
number one for University of Wisconsin I
was like would it be so [__] up if
like I just forgot how to serve and then
my mind would like do it to me is that
like the twisties in gymnastics yeah
it's so like what
um yeah The Yips The Yips yeah and I
would do it with my forehand like
because I'd just be sitting around with
my anxious mind and I'd be like what's
the worst thing that could happen and
then I would like make it happen because
I'm disciplined but it was now I realize
my body was like you don't want to be a
competitor anymore like I'm so
competitive but I actually like girls
like loved competing I loved practice I
hated Judgment Day when I had to beat a
girl because if I won I was just like
hang on and if I lost I was like now I
have to face the music that I'm the
worst tennis player in the world I
actually really loved class and
rehearsal more than performing too which
is weird because now we're both
performers for a living but this
performing I really feel like it's just
so expressive like I'm Gonna Leave This
pod and I'm not gonna be like you're
lost or you won I'm just like that was
fun you don't my friend I think that all
the time and at least third and I'm like
[__] I that was I have to train myself
because you can't live your life like
having to like I'm like I'm not playing
a game anymore I'm just expressing
myself and I'm proud of myself that like
I got invited on a cool pod today can I
tell you guys a [__] up story
so last year I was supposed to compete
in the Nationals for spearfishing and I
I did I feel like I can't I'm not alone
I can't wait what I'm gonna be number
one spearfisher in the planet you know
it was just fresh it was it's not even
it was just freshwater Nationals and I
was gonna
okay got it now now this is the cover of
like spear fishing Central I'm not that
great of a spearfisher woman yet but I
will get there I have friends like Kimmy
Werner and Valentine Thomas who are like
Aces but I was supposed to compete and I
was supposed to be in a team with my
friend Matt and we were and and the
whole time like a month out immediately
like I was in the worst mood I was
bitching everyone out I was just the
worst mental mindset and I swear to you
I swear to you two weeks out I got
covered and I thanked the [__]
Heavens I was like thank you so much
whoever just gave me covid because it
was a good enough reason to pull out and
then another girl replaced me and they
won like second place they were
incredible it's hard because you're
taught to like push through any nerves
that's how you become a champion push
through when you're tired so you can't
tell when you actually like just don't
want to do it just for you like I got
hit by a car my senior year but like I
was totally fine but it was enough to
like [__] up my like Big Ten
championship and I remember I got hit by
car first thing I said was tell my coach
I'm gonna be late to practice because I
was so scared I'm really into that I
literally was like wait the universe
[__] my [__] up like that's a once
thing that the Universe does to me like
they will [__] me up to get me out of
situations it's never like a casual
thing it's always like you're gonna hit
by a car you're gonna like big things
because the universe knows that I will
fight I'm a fighter I will try so I'm a
singer yeah you gotta push me exactly I
will cling to like my life depends on it
and then finally I was like I hear you I
see you
I I
I will leave I will leave this sport
that I love and I like I I made a
conscious decision after college I'm not
gonna go pro and my body was telling me
to leave I was like your body tells you
and I say it's like surfing I don't know
why I looked at you but you act like you
can serve I I can but I'm not good I
mean I'm sorry I didn't look at you but
I feel like you would just float away I
can't
[Applause]
[Laughter]
but it's like surfing when you find the
right wave you [__] go do you need a
focus do you have the right technique do
you have to like stay whatever yes but
when you find that wave you flow and all
the other waves will feel really [__]
difficult so it's like find your wave oh
wow
we're doing water metaphors and and then
just spear that fish yeah you know what
when I spear the fish I Cry
really really hard I'm not over that
part yet see why did we pick something
[Laughter]
because I would cry I like
I think like Karma's gonna come get me
like an even an ant I mean same I I I'm
terrified of cockroaches but I will
escort one out yeah give it a little
I'll ask my neighbor to come to my house
the guy I don't know to escort the
Cockroach out
core memories in Dan in like a dance
rehearsal was when the head of our
studio was watching us rehearse and it
was like a week before the show where I
had the lead and she I just remember her
screaming in front of everyone Esther
you're standing out in a bad way and
that like has stuck with me and I think
that ultimately a couple years later
when I made the decision to quit I was
like I think I do stand out in a bad way
like and that was like that became this
metaphor of like I'm not supposed to be
like in this herd of dancers or you know
oh my God I stand out in a bad way
period like that's who I am and I think
that's stand-up comedians like you could
say that about everybody yeah but that
is so true because I told you like with
tennis all the girls were very robotic
and I I'm I was never like that like I
was always aware of everything I was
like crazy on the court I would be like
come on like I was a character and I was
like I feel different but I know I'm not
like that special so why am I like
sticking out
like a sore thong yeah yeah I I I was
like I realized too a part of why I
loved dance class was that when I went
there I was the goofball and like made
everyone laugh and so it all like I
slowly figured it out that it was time
to leave I my like one skill I would get
nervous all the time with playing but
the one thing I always could do was make
my doubles partner laugh when she was in
a bad mood like I would double fall I'd
do everything wrong but she'd play bad
when she got angry so like my job was to
just keep her happy and it was I could
do it in my sleep I knew exactly what to
say but never thought I thought I could
monetize that stupid skill
actually I cried I used to cry when I
first tried working out after college
after tennis because I'd go to the gym
and I just be reminded like I used to
work out to become a champion
why am I here I'm a loser I and my my
body would shut down I cry and I I'd be
on the treadmill for like seven minutes
and I give up like I've had coaches like
throw water at me smack me in the head
like just keep running and we'll tell
you when to stop like doing planks on a
tennis court that's like it starts
melting the bottom of your elbows like
[__] up [__] but that was just like
being a champion yeah I I was just
telling a dog I'm sorry how was it I was
at the gym this morning and I was
telling um my trainer like he was like
Lila like you know I cannot tell when
you're at your limit because it's like
like I think Dr Drew calls it like poor
second order representation so it's
almost like I dissociate through pain so
if it's the last couple reps and I'm
really like pushing it I just I'm like
flat like flat there's like no emotions
out of me but
um I realized where that's from
um when I was 12 I was this was like the
Philippine national games and I was
expected because I was like the the I
held the record in a certain event and a
200 meter brush stroke and then I lost
and everyone was like she wasn't
supposed to lose that race my sister was
in the race with me I lost their race so
young and I will send you guys just like
newspaper clippings of me like
everyone took a picture of me crying in
like four different ways from this angle
I was 12 years old and then on the
caption on it was kalila fails to hold
back tears after her loss in why are
these people so invested
12 year old you're you're literally
learning what your reality is that's
that is [__] that is like a form of
public humiliation it is it is and then
um but then my trainer said something
funny he was like well you kind of went
through like a weird like public
humiliation last year you know with the
whole breakup with Bobby and he was like
do you think that like a part of you is
just kind of like block going through
that same thing of like can't cry I
can't do this can't do I'm like what I
do is like because I went through public
relationship recently too and I just
um I get depressed but then I just like
become a workaholic like I just put my
mind towards because all we know is like
to just keep working but I'm working on
feeling my feelings I don't really know
what that means they don't know what
that means but I'm like I'm upset I've
been upset what do you want me to feel
so but thank you for sharing that
because like that stuff sticks with you
like hearing one person say like I'm
disappointed in you like that stuff
shakes you to your core yeah but to be
have that be so public like I don't know
I just that keeps happening in our
culture and it's gonna it's going to
keep happening probably and I just
I don't know it's cool because I know
that that happened to you in a way and
you
like became a superstar stand-up
comedian out of it and so I do think
that like that don't wouldn't you say
that that humiliation at 12 like made
you a [__] fighter for the rest of
your life yeah no it made me fight and
that's the one thing that you said
earlier that really like I can really
relate to is like it does not matter how
down in the dumps or in the [__] pits
of hell I am like I'm I'm fighting like
tooth and nail to get out of there
quotes this is such a sports podcast I'm
obsessed with us right now we are ESPN
okay look there's no secret that I like
candy and I'm not afraid I'm not ashamed
to say that and I do believe that that
is why native was manifested into my
life or how I manifested them to make
this Candy Shop collection you guys
native products are thoughtfully
formulated they keep us feeling and
smelling deliciously fresh all day long
and you know native for their aluminum
free deodorant native keeps their
ingredients list bare naked with
ingredients you understand like coconut
oil shea butter and baking soda native
deodorant checks a lot of boxes for a 72
hour odor protection naturally derived
ingredients smooth residue free
application they also offer a variety of
scents and new limited edition scents
being released all the time which is
obviously my favorite thing about them
and when you use native you will smell
amazing all day long thanks to their
long lasting scents there's woodsy
there's Spicy Sweet clean fresh okay
you've got lots of options but do not
miss the Limited Edition Candy Shop
collection they've got gummy bears
strawberry and vanilla Taffy sour Berry
belts you guys me and Annie are eating
each other's armpits out it's a problem
right now go to nativedeo.com trash
Tuesday or use promo code trash Tuesday
at checkout to get a sweet 20 off your
first order that's
nativedeo.com trash Tuesday or use promo
code trash Tuesday at checkout for 20
off your first order we highly recommend
the candy shop collection
come from like a sports fan like my
grandpa was a gym teacher like in
Brooklyn like would gay kids off the
street and be like you're gonna be a
basketball player like he was like the
guy who watched movies recruiting random
literally he was fine just like tall
guys in the neighborhood he's like you
37 fine get on the team but he always
said to me even when it's raining the
hoop is always there
um I [__] love that quote to this day
because it's like you know when you're
depressed and you're like there's no
hope he's basically saying the hoop is
there you can always score you just
can't see it because it's raining we
it's so similar to ballet too I don't
know if you guys have seen Center Stage
I watch I have oh my God I love the
center stage I watch every morning but
like there's a scene where she's like
the bar is always here like the ballet
bar and it's like you can always go back
to the ballet bar and do your Plies and
do your tandoos and like that's always
there like no one can take that for me I
mean I guess if I get hurt but but it's
all perspective like you can feel like
it's not there and feel like you're
flailing yeah but you're the one who can
decide that like this is gonna be okay
and I feel like those traumatizing
things that we've all been through
I was telling Esther I'm just less
scared now like I'm like what's gonna
happen to me today that I haven't
already dealt with where when you're
younger you're like all these bad things
could happen and I'm like they've
happened and I'm still here still
bloated still thriving
I've recently connected with a friend of
mine who was like very publicly canceled
a few years ago and it's been
interesting like
now that like he's gone through all this
trauma and what's left of him is
truly just who he is wow and like his
creative expression and I've just been
very inspired by that like
you they no one can take that from you
you know like who you are and how you
express yourself and your ideas and your
mind like those don't go anywhere even
if everybody in the world hates you and
thinks this and that about you well
depends what you're canceled for True um
because if you're just a [__] [__]
Predator okay true well yeah if if
you've been canceled because people are
trying to come for you and it's like or
whatever public accumulation I like to
call it you have like an ego death
because at some point people don't
cancel people who aren't like have
something to be canceled so like you
have ego with whatever's going on so
once that gets taken away it's true
you're naked you're bare and ego deaths
are powerful because then you realize
it's like with our sports like tennis
there was so much ego associated with it
that gave me anxiety but like now like
with your ballet if you can what I say
like that
if she was famous that's not what they
say in rock climbing oh yeah because you
wouldn't know about rock climbing
so I feel like if so she's my if I was
cool that would be Kyla
I feel like with ballet
once you can get the ego out of it then
you're just there and you don't care
what the girl is that's for the love
it's just because you're like I'm moving
my body I'm so capable I'm so good at
this I forget sometimes like I'll be
struggling and then I'll go hit a tennis
ball and I'm like wait there's something
I'm like actually really good at that I
just forgot but detach the ego and then
it becomes this fun beautiful thing that
we are just capable of and it's it
doesn't have all these other voices
attached to it Hannah since we last saw
you you are now officially an MRS oh my
God yes I am de-centering men from my
life but I am married no I literally on
stage I think I just told this last week
but I go on I want my opener on
Valentine's Day was like
who wants to hear from a sad lonely girl
on Valentine's Day I mean I am engaged
but
um I joke that being married was like
bad for my brand and like people don't
know I'm married like every now and then
it'll come up and people like lose their
mind but it's like the least interesting
thing about me and I have a podcast
called giggly Squad that we recorded two
days ago we literally forgot that it was
Valentine's Day did not talk about
Valentine's Day and I'm like wait I'm
we're I'm so proud of us we literally
forgot to talk we didn't talk about
plans like we just it didn't come up in
the hour we spoke
and we passed
but yeah like I'm married and it's and
it's so nice to have like a partner
um but like it's
I just have this thing where like I
don't want anyone to dim my light I feel
like relationships could be so toxic and
it's like be single until you find
someone who can just like support you do
you did you have a good experience
having a wedding I'm on the fence about
having one do you have any pro tips um
my only other thing I would have done is
eloped I love an elopement still my plan
I do think
but I also was like kind of cheap at the
time like I remember afterwards being
like
it was amazing but was it worth the
money
but that was also me I I'd never like
dreamed of a wedding it never was like
my thing it ended up being such a
beautiful like
moment in time of your life like you I
felt the weight of it like I was when I
was I was getting adrenaline and stuff
like during the vows and stuff which I
didn't think I would have oh but like
you you feel like the moment the weight
of the moment hits you I just like the
critic in me there were all these little
microaggressions that would happen
against women throughout it like about
like well lose you know three pounds to
faint his wedding dress and like you
know how are we gonna have your dad give
you off to him like little things that I
just was like I'm not I'm not engaging
in this and I didn't like like
I don't like that attention I love
attention I don't like the attention of
people like not being forced but like
you have to celebrate me when I didn't
do anything I totally relate to this and
this doesn't make sense I feel like you
just so perfectly articulated why I
don't want a wedding because me and my
fiance are at a standstill he wants one
I don't I want to elope so badly yeah um
and the walking down the aisle thing I
my dad is 80 years old he's my best
friend in the whole world I have
screamed in his face ew you're not
giving up
people need to talk about it because my
friend Ashley has a Time who his girl's
gotta eat podcast she's like my father's
not giving me away I make more money
than him
and it was literally iconic but what
happened with me is my my dad and my mom
walk me down and all I was thinking in
my head is you have to give the bouquet
to one of them and then go up I give the
bouquet to my mom and then I just walked
up like I forgot to like kiss my dad I
didn't do it I just forgot and I wasn't
going to a clue then my dad and I the
father-daughter dance we're like best
friends 30 seconds in we were like we
can't we literally quit like my dad he
we were like this we're laughing I think
he like he kind of like shoved me like a
joke and then I was like we're not I'm
not playing this game with you I'm not
doing a father Daddy dance with my dad
who I literally just like all we do [__]
on each other all the time it actually
my people were like oh they're done like
20 seconds and we just stopped we were
like come on guys it was there were a
lot of awkward Parts but I would argue
to like make him happy too because it is
whatever his day I mean it's not really
but your dad or your husband your
husband okay your husband I would do a
small thing that has whatever you feel
will be nice and we'd like I I changed a
lot of things to make it less
traditional and comfortable for me
okay that okay maybe did you guys read
your own vows or did you have a question
so it was on the beach it ended up being
quite the wedding I have to say like it
went from like a garage wedding to like
Hamptons like oh my God
but I actually had a wedding planner who
I just like trusted like I gave her all
my inspo and then the day of the wedding
I saw what it looked like like Oh I like
that I loved it all I trusted she was
gonna be better than me at it it's like
with like designing your home yeah I
want I don't know how to do it yes she
crushed it and so I was surprised we we
did like traditional ish vows I was very
not into like I don't want this mumbo
jumbo about love and like religion I
don't need that yeah no one knows what
it means if we had the we had people
heckling US during the because we have
comedians in the crowd reality TV people
who are black out one girl like fell and
she they were like wow like they were
yelling it was crazy the the judge who
officiated was like a family friend who
was hilarious so we were dying laughing
and then dozes of Irish descent so they
have the right in the groom give a
speech during the reception which I was
like not really about I'm like I don't
need to perform on my big day
but he goes up and he's murdering like
murdering lasts per minute and saying
people he's like serving and then I
start looking at my phone calls me out
he's like she knows she's no she's
looking at her phone for her notes and I
was like okay now I need to take you the
[__] down so then I go for my speech
I you have to slow it down right like if
someone's killing before you slow it
down you bring people down you almost
make them nervous is she bombing what's
gonna happen I bring him down to nothing
and then I'm like I wish sometimes that
I was able to like grow with you like
you're 47 I met you at 30. I wish I knew
who does was when he was younger I wish
I met you when like you were 20 years
old but I would have been in
kindergarten and then the place like
corrupted I got an Applause break I
looked in the eye and I was like don't
ever [__] with me again and that was our
way
I love that and like I always joke that
I wish that Dave and I had met earlier
but I would have been too young so I
always say that I think we met on the
streets of New York when I was there
with my dance teacher in eighth grade
and he was an adult working in a city
for his job in the morning yeah like I'm
like we must have caught each other's
eyes we knew from long ago but you know
what the best part because during it
it's all like everything has to be
formal everyone's like what we're
supposed to do
then we did the after party across the
street at this like beach bar
and that was everything because you
don't care anymore you're like anything
could happen like when my bridesmaids
could like puke her brains out no one
cares we were like dancing on the bar
and it was that was the best time and
yeah I that night we had sex it was
crazy like humble brag I realized I just
hadn't taken my birth control for a week
because I'm horrible with it
and I realized I was ovulating oof I'll
explain what that is to your producers
later
[Laughter]
I'd wake up and we like have to go this
like little brunch and I was like do you
want to have a baby because I was like I
I know my luck like I'll get pregnant
did he go go inside you yeah he go goad
and and he looked at me and he's like I
kind of want to travel for like two to
three years you're 47 he's like I kind
of want to go skiing more and I'm like
okay
so I'm like okay let's travel to CVS
I got a plan B I have like a whole bit
about it how like you know when you're
in a Walgreens normally it's so fun but
then when you're going for a plan B the
place just closing closes in yeah and
you can't find it you can't find it's in
the Family Planning family I'm planning
I don't know what to do so I took a Plan
B my wedding we need to get you a deal
with Julie Julie is a plan B is just
boring and so medical and so scary to
look at sad but there's Julie is the new
con Julie's a new contraception I would
love it's like in cute colors and makes
you feel hot no like the guy had to take
out like a Cleaver to like break down no
walking to let me yeah that's what I'm
saying no attention grabbing I'm like
I'm trying to be subtle here that I'm
irresponsible with my [__] and you're
like telling the whole entire Walgreens
no when I pick up a Julie I'm waving
that thing around the aisle you're like
I'm like look at me
have one in her purses at all times like
here kalila well that's what you did you
got me one um oh yeah for our live
stream no you need we need to do a
campaign of you with a Julie the morning
after your wedding so what's so funny is
we decided because we were on reality TV
he was on for like a second and people
just take whatever they want from it
they like monetize it they spin any
story they want to whatever you feel
kind of used and abused with your
relationship so we were like I'm not
doing an article on it I'm not doing
like a Brides like this is just for us
if it gets picked up by someone's photo
fine but just for us but I knew people
were like looking at my Instagram like
what you gonna post so my first post was
my like wedding band holding the plan b
yeah it would have been better contrast
for the photo just overall very
editorial tutorial yeah no but I by the
way I just want to say that I love
living your life for the storyline like
I love an Instagram post that's just
like yeah [__] I'm a hoe after my
wedding like I I don't know that's like
my kind of [__] content I literally
joked that it's like I lost my virginity
on my wedding night but I didn't
um but I'm dealing with some issues now
because my husband loves skiing and I
wasn't a skier growing up because I was
a tennis player and God forbid I got
injured skiing so I was like not allowed
to ski and my family like didn't really
have them like you had to be like loaded
I feel like yeah that's very rich before
yeah like skiing was not part of the
conversation so he skis
and I learned and obviously I'm really
competitive so I wanted to become like
the best skier I could be I'm like I'm
going to be in the Olympics and he was
obviously I married someone like my dad
so like in the morning I did three hour
lessons after noon I would show him what
I learned and I should probably talk to
a therapist about it but I got like
pretty good and now he like wants to go
skiing all the time and I
it's so embarrassing I don't love it
like I have to go to Whistler next week
to ski with him okay but do you have to
go can we like talk about how you can
just say no before but you have to do
here's I think this is how it works it
should work you don't have to do all the
things he loves but you have to do one
or two things but we're like the best
friends we're like we we love all the
same things you and your husband yeah so
skiing can just not be one of them but
like skiing is his most favorite thing
and I'm such a like I want my dad to
love me you know like I want him he
wakes up and I'll tell him like once I
was like my tof my toenail fell off like
I can't do this anymore and he's like
you're not gonna come skiing with me
today Hannah if you were if you were
like no like my toenail is on the floor
and he's like it'll go numb soon because
of the ice so like it'll be fine and I'm
like I know you're doing this to me
I know you're a fighter and this is
speaking of Fallen toenails
um when I was in after I quit swimming I
went through the identity crisis and I
was like I'm gonna just stay an athlete
however which way I can so I started
running like 13 miles a day so all my
toenails would fall off and I would just
paint the meat oh
[__] nasty like I can't even imagine
touching the meat underneath the toenail
that in fact you called it meat what's
the raw chicken I'm a fighter no I had
no feeling in my toes at that point you
have no feeling anywhere they're numb to
everything it's funny because my toenail
finally grew back but like with curves
so I'm like she's learning to love
herself like people be like what is that
and I'm like she learns to love her
curves okay
foreign
oh my goodness boy oh boy do I love
neutrophone I am so excited and tickled
and stoked that they are our sponsors I
love neutral I use it every day I take
four pills every single day it makes my
hair grow on so much thicker it's a hot
girl product guys it just works it's
something that we used before we started
this podcast it's something that we have
been using consistently throughout this
podcast it's a rare product that the
three of us agree on like wholeheartedly
and it's neutral and 30 million women
are impacted by weakened or thinning
hair and if you're among them you are
not alone and there is a solution that
you can trust to deliver results
neutriful is the number one
dermatologist recommended hair growth
supplement clinically shown to improve
your hair growth thickness and visible
scalp coverage now dermatologists May
recommend it that's fine and good but
when the trash Tuesday Queens yeah I'll
call us Queens when we recommend it I
think that should mean a little more
than a doctor I don't know about you but
kalila has shown me photos of results
before and after that's what got me
hooked on it and in a clinical study 86
of women reported improved hair growth
after six months side note Annie is
never consistent with anything I've
never seen her anywhere without having
her neutral in her purse you can grow
thicker healthier hair and support our
show by going to neutrifold.com and
entering the promo code trash to save 15
off your first month's subscription this
is their best offer anywhere and it is
only available to us customers for a
limited time plus free shipping on every
order get 15 off at nutriful.com spelled
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l.com promo code trash
foreign
[Music]
disappear when you're older I mean we
talked my nana and I still got it my
grandma's like posting on Instagram like
a full influencer at 82 years old it's
so inspiring and she no she out she
should see Valentine's Day she's pink
she has the patterns like every like
outfits and like we have to remember
that like you're still alive yeah bro
you don't have to give up on everything
just because you got old oh [__] the way
that our society has treated old people
like they're supposed to just disappear
and La old people that means you're like
38 right yeah I'm moments away in fact
you know what when I'm 80 I'm gonna be
waving that box of Julie and yeah
still impregnable women are so [__]
like they know everything they're so
confident they're so I don't I like
aspire to be it I told you Barbara
Corcoran is like I love Barbara Corcoran
like I look up to her there's this thing
that she says like over and over again
is like she always believes in people
that are a little broken wait she DM me
on Instagram no no I had a full freak
out Mama
she's like you need help but yeah she
it's I was talking to Esther about how
like some girls they Dr you dream of you
like different things and I was always
the kind of girl I did not care about
being the prettiest girl in the room I
wanted to be Barbara Corcoran I wanted
to be like Chelsea Handler I wanted to
be like that Vibe and like that has
nothing to do with the wrinkles on your
face no and also I'm just I'm ready to
I'm not giving up like if I have the
privilege of becoming a little old lady
like I want to You're Gonna I'm gonna
fight the fight wait you're gonna be
such an iconic older lady but like I
don't know if I can handle your cuteness
because old people are cute in general
oh my God I'm just getting cuter
you're like Jack Harlow you're just
getting cuter but as you get older I
mean the good and bad news is that your
testosterone starts to kind of
um move upwards what does that mean um
which means I kind of want to see that
testosterone version
[__] like they're just so tough yeah and
then the man they're after tends to
compete more with their testosterone
that's why there's this myth of like the
sweet young man and the cranky old lady
because it's like the hormones start to
kind of shift in an older age those will
be less grumpy over time yeah
interesting I've never stop waking up at
7am because that's awesome what is that
honestly I mean I've never had that no
no 6 7 P.M
glad the opposite so 12 hours after yeah
just reversed no but um I I'm I keep
looking around in my life I'm like am I
the only one that hates waking up this
early like I like to roll around in bed
and dissociate for two hours before I
even do a single thing oh yeah I do not
pop out of bed I thought I need to go on
like Wellbutrin or something but it's
like I think that's just me and I'm the
most creative and Hyper at like 11. but
then I was thinking because of like
having to do two a days working so hard
I always remember fantasizing like when
I have some autonomy in my life I'm
gonna take a nap I'm gonna sleep in
those are my two priorities when I'm
done swimming I'm gonna sleep in and I'm
gonna take swimmers you had to like wake
up at like three maybe in the Water by
five yeah that is so abusive yeah it's
[__] up and it was cold and it's like
the pools are heated to like maybe upper
70s but it's like 35 degrees out in the
winter and you're like I don't want to
be wet right 5 a.m you are so much
stronger than me like it's I'm pathetic
the fact that you're in a cold pool at
5A a.m ever even once it's like I you
could crush me with your hand
I'm such a [__] nothing
um no okay surviving ballet school thank
you yeah that's something that is you
should talk to someone that is like
after that you I think I would argue and
say you went through maybe the most
psychological warfare like that's my
nightmare yeah because you have to worry
about your weight your aesthetic like
when you're just a slim when you're I'm
a swimmer and athlete like I don't give
a [__] how crazy yeah putting your hair
in a bun these are things that I never
had me neither never I would I smell
like chlorine I was crusty as [__] I was
probably like walking around with bcecs
because of [__] wet [__] swimsuit
was up my [__] all day you know so it's
like I never cared about that but like
ballet is a completely different story
it's like looks are everything oh my God
I'm a somebody
I'm gonna ask you guys something what
kind and I don't think this has
necessarily anything to do with
you know the person that you are or it
might but how
or when do you fill up your gas tag and
when do you charge your phone do you
wait till it's dead do you wait till
there's five miles left in your tank
um what do you do do you run on empty do
you live on the edge oh my God you're
totally catching me in my most shameful
like literally for the last 15 years of
my adult life living in La like my when
I moved here when my dad walked me down
out to the driveway and I was on the
drive to Los Angeles when I was 21 or
something yeah he said always fill your
gas tank when it's half full
and I've never done it once I always
wait it sounds like does talking to me I
don't listen I always wait till it's on
E and every time it's on E I feel like
[__] [__] and I I'm like oh my God
I'm a mess I'm a loser and my worst fear
is to be driving in the car run out of
gas that has not happened but are you
seeking the thrill no I realize I
realized at this point in my life I like
the drama no I think so I think I do too
it makes you feel alive I don't like it
I don't I swear and I've even been in
situations where it's like 3 A.M and I'm
in like a weird area and I have to get
gas and I'm like if I get killed this is
my fault it's a good story to tell also
I would examine that and maybe get on
board with me and Hannah I'm telling you
there is a something there that I'm not
admitting to where I'm like am I just
lazy am I just putting this off till the
end but I need a little bit of like
feeling like oh this could go bad before
I do anything
I think it's laziness for me but
laziness is a myth remember but it's
also like you don't know that girl like
the one who's like I'll be fine I'll go
right that girl's not getting it later
and like you never could you know yeah
we yeah yeah who is she
she's never coming home
Jesus is never coming back that girl is
never and you feel so like betrayed by
her like when you're on empty you're
like you were there like you who was
that happy that decided to [__] me now
she doesn't care about me she doesn't
love me but then you'll be her the next
day and be like she's fine anyway I have
I have too many voices in my head fun
facts about me is because I'm a New
Yorker I don't drive okay so that lucky
I honestly think I couldn't handle the
admin of all that but I have done this
thing where like my phone I'm I'm
routine oriented like I'm a little bit
like a cat with certain things I just
need routine so it's like at night I
charge my phone but every now and then
it'll be like at 15 and I'm starting to
fall asleep and I'm like I don't really
want to get up and put in the charger
and I will say I will figure it out in
the morning
I go to sleep and do you figure it out
in the morning um it gets hectic it's
crazy right Hoover Chargers I'm going to
random bars you're blaming people around
you yeah yeah yeah I'm not speaking to
my family
I get a divorce but so yeah I
I just ice that Hannah doesn't respect
the other Hannah like I say yes to
everything and then the day of I'm like
who which Hannah thought this was okay I
have to say this is a skill that I've
worked on over the years and I feel very
confident in my abilities here and one
of my tricks with it is would I do it
today yep would I do it tomorrow and
that has really helped me and like I
think I've told you guys this before but
I for a year me and my college friends
did this thing like 20 uh it was like
2019 no flake and so if we flaked on
anything we had to do a punishment for
the other person
yeah I am a cult leader if you don't
know that by now you're in the
documentary on Netflix if I started
watching it I'm obsessed by mother God
wait which documentary it's the Sarah
Lawrence sex call oh I haven't seen it
yet the third episode not there yet but
excited blew my mind okay the second one
you're like okay this is really [__]
up and then third one I was sobbing I
was screaming throwing up it like in a
beautiful way but I'm very recovered at
saying I I but now I almost say no to
everything although now okay so how do
you decipher because you say would I do
this tonight yeah and also it's like
when you go a year where if you flake on
something you have to do a punishment
you get it in your system you're like
I'm not saying yes if I'm not might not
go but so you how did you get over the
like I'm letting this person down
feeling that's really easy for me that's
just the natural
Born This Way kind of thing I don't give
a [__] like I don't know anyone anything
are you insane like what I don't know
why immediately like if someone's like
hey can you do my show tonight if I just
say no like as a full sentence no I feel
like they'll be like she's a [__] she's
a demon I just say I can't make it I'm
I'm sorry I'm that person like a full
excuse for you I'd be like my ovaries
bleeding like I can't I'm yeah I think
I'm dying I have just driven in circles
in bad neighborhoods looking for parking
too many nights to say yes to random
shows true and if I don't fill my cup
first I have no cups to fill for anyone
you're healthier much healthier than me
in that way like I really like no to a
lot of stuff well me all the time I can
say no but like Hannah I feel pretty
terrible like there will be like a like
you know like a three-page apology yeah
um but it's also because we're trained
to like be able to do anything and not
care about our own feelings so I'm not
that in touch with it like I'm like I'd
rather them be happy with me like that
feels better right I'm gonna be
miserable that day everyone is coach
everyone is coach like that's how I
treat it it's like if I if I what can I
do so that you you know like me better
in this moment or you respect me more in
this moment it's never just like I can
get it for myself but it's obviously
it's I'm a lot better now I'm a little
bit more therapized now but my instinct
is always to do the full-blown
explanation you know what's funny about
that what you just said is like oh how
come if my answer is about like you know
pleasing the other person not only are
you betraying yourself you're betraying
me because I don't want you to show up
if you don't want to be there like then
now I feel you know what I mean but
coach never really cared I'm calling him
coaches like figure no but that is so
powerful but it's so funny that my
therapist told me that they're like
you've betrayed yourself yeah
because I mean even like playing tennis
every day you have to betray yourself to
consciously wake up that early perform
on every day you feel horrible that you
literally don't write yourself it's in
your body and your your habits your
system yeah my I I do think some friends
like really love the plans and the
hanging out more than others and like
whole friendships will be ruined by like
someone canceling on things like some
people are like high maintenance like
that which like Iris I respect they find
each other
my best friends and I our thing is
flaking same she literally like first of
all it's a it's abusive and this is a
strong word that was a strong word it's
not abusive but it's like a lot for you
to I'm chilling you asked me to do
something I didn't ask to do and then I
have to feel bad to say no so like
everything we do I go you can totally
cancel I don't even want to do it do you
want to do this tonight okay so that's
how my friendship structure works too
where it's like because they understand
that there's probably like deep
codependency happening so it's like we
have a full safe policy of canceling and
everyone just accepts it even if it's
last minute like oh like and you don't
ask those people to do things that are
like important right but like like I
have a friend that I will never ask to
do something that's like very important
but I love her to death yeah I feel like
she's canceled on me so many times and
I've always been okay with it because
it's like part of our friendship yeah I
think that's healthy but like a phone
call she's always there for me but to
physically ask her to be somewhere is
can I okay so this is totally unrelated
but you know the the current sitting
president of the Philippines one of the
reasons he won was because he won
um basic social media he won Tick Tock
he basically had a whole team generate
all of these false things about him I
mean that's the whole world like right
right right but one of the craziest
things that people really fell for was
that he discovered Michael Jordan
we're just thinking of that as a lie
that's like my father invented toaster
strudel I have iconic lie so he's like
George Santos of tick tock yeah
basically that he because he's a Marcos
and a Marcos in the Philippines was he
was like basically like a [__] he
didn't put martial law Philippines no
dictator bad bad bad history but then
their son is now the sitting president
and one of the stories out there was
that he visited I don't know it was like
where's where's Michael Jordan from
North Carolina yeah this is the
propaganda right here okay there we go
so here I'll read it to you guys on
December 24th 1969 the Marcos family was
in Wilmington North Carolina to
celebrate the holidays president
Ferdinand Marcos was walking in a park
and he saw a skinny child begging for
food no he gave him a whole box of
nutribun and said bring this with you
child someday you will grow grow up to
be someone important the kid grew up to
be Michael
discovery that you're not he did he
wasn't playing basketball you're getting
a kid food also that seems like just I
don't that is so [__] up but I have
family members who believe this because
I'm like why did you vote for this guy
and they were like he discovered my
culture from the Philippines like of all
the vacation you're not going all the
way across the world to go to Wilmington
oh God that is a beautiful life I have
uncles who will fight me on this that is
the most [__] thing I've ever heard
also I wouldn't remember the name of a
kid that I gave food to
and I've never remembered any person
I've given food to
no yeah that's I'm just like what can I
think of yeah yeah Esther we should come
up with something this is like me
thinking I met Dave in 2002 Middle
School in New York City like I just
believe it or like it's my I'm like
because I also believe that I remember
the day I was born like and that's
obviously a lie but I believe it so well
that's kind of like the cult thing yeah
where cult leaders will tell you facts
about your life based off like give me a
little truth and I'll tell you what
actually happened if I tell you it
enough you believe it's a real memory
and then all your memories are [__] up
and then you believe your family
poisoned you this has happened to me
before Believe It or Not several times
in fact Dave watched the Sarah Lawrence
thing and he was like you would fall for
this he's like you're so lucky you
weren't there you would have this you
would have been all about this because
we're athletes I do believe we'll fall
for anything yeah because like we're
like someone's like I see greatness in
here
I'm sold like I'm literally done like do
you want to be a better person and you
just follow my rules and then you'll
take over the world I'll be like
absolutely and next thing you know I'm
like murdering because I was also very
praise deprived that praise is my Kink
but but now I just like I don't
necessarily require it but when I do
hear it it's I could come you know so
you're right I see greatness in you lit
that's how my hair just stood up because
also these these women in these Cults
and men are a lot of really smart
successful type A people it's like why
narcissists come for people like you
because when they love bomb you you're
like finally someone [__] realized in
three days that I'm perfect
finally because he sees me for me and
I'm actually [__] great I have
confidence and then they suck it all out
oh God I'm so susceptible to that I but
I feel that I am the perfect mix of
exactly perfect to be recruited into a
cult and also exactly ready to be a cult
leader like I'm both of those things I
also think you could be the mole in
there that could dismantle the whole
thing yeah that's right I think sweet
you said I do
no I really believe that too because the
fact that you could be the leader but
you don't just want to be the leader
makes me feel like you'd start a
rebellion hmm okay oh that's a that's a
hotter rule 20 23 plans for me find I
don't know in the apocalypse I'll find
you yeah guide me I'll be a good you can
be the second iteration of mother God
okay she's the love is one um cult
leader right
you died from like she died look at how
she's sitting now she's sitting
differently how scares yourself
differently actually us together
if you can be the leader we will be the
muscle yeah we will be your bodyguards
and you can convince us to do any crazy
[__] and we'll do it we're just your
oxen really yeah this is what I've
always wanted well carry you around your
athletic prowess it is who I am your
feet will never have to touch the ground
ever again
oh
let me sit there and you're just petting
your little dog
over here and you give us praise
sometimes but then you take it away ugh
that's so I honestly that's so mean I
can't do it like I have had that happen
to me that I'm like I won't do that to
anyone I'll just like no I can't you
tell kalilah she's standing out but not
in the good way
oh my God all right it's been so much
Esther
too much if we start to kind of enjoy
ourselves or talk oh yeah
much not too much
no more giggling
um this has been so much [__] fun oh
my God I love you guys you belong here
oh my God literally every time I'm in
L.A I'll just sit on the rug just have
your flight land right outside here walk
off the flight I'm but it's so funny
because this is like the only pod that
I've like really fangirled for I just
when the three of you were all together
I just was like oh those are my people
and when I first went on it I was like
nervous I was like so excited and then I
think I said the name wrong that's how
you know I was like really nervous to be
there I was like I love this pod Tuesday
trashes
I'm a huge fan of the of giggly Squad
and of burning in Hell thank you love
you first Esther was on yeah great
khalila I I'm like would love to have
you one of us of course and I just had
you on my solo podcast my pleasure you
killed it we had so much fun
um this has been wonderful anything else
people can come see or stand up on the
road you're the queen of tick tock oh my
God I'm a full tick tocker now
um that's all I care about in life I
have an addiction same but I'm gonna be
in New York City in Boston and Richmond
and Miami coming up so honeyburn.com
check it out we love that and you guys
thank you so much for being here with us
we will see you next week with a brand
new episode until then
um my feet are you're the boss of you
hi guys
[Music]
before